je veux juste que quelque chose ait plus de temps
dans ma main que d'heures dans la journée
où le reste n'a jamais atteint le quota mes
unités sont en hausse par rapport à la semaine dernière donc le
quota est de
deux heures ça a toujours été une heure maintenant
c'est deux le prix a augmenté c'est un deux  -heure de
marche j'ai une heure et demie alors tu
ferais mieux de courir
les pauvres sont censés mourir c'est comme ça que le
système fonctionne
comment c'est censé être
tu ne sais vraiment pas
quel âge as-tu en temps réel 28. je suis
105.
la vérité est qu'il y a plus qu'assez de
temps pour tout le monde un troisième homme avec un
million d'années alors que la plupart du temps
pour que quelques-uns soient immortels, beaucoup doivent mourir
personne ne devrait être immortel si même une
personne doit mourir
vous n'êtes pas du coin  voici toi pourquoi
adopterais-tu que tu es un peu
différent viens avec moi la caméra a
capté un comportement suspect son nom
est salas
il ne devrait pas être là qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire voler le vol s'il est déjà
volé
je vais  faites les payer
allez aidez vous prenez le temps
c'est
gratuit  Avant de comprendre que nous ne pouvons pas avoir
mille ans entre de mauvaises mains, vous
pourriez paralyser le système, je vais l'arrêter,
le problème est que
tout le monde veut vivre éternellement,
nous ne sommes pas censés vivre éternellement
, espérons que
son crime était '  il ne prenait pas de temps
il
te le donnait